this is how the battle for her son is
being fought
Crews targeting Russian forces just
kilometers away
they have the coordinates it's a quick
two shots
and then they have to move
we had to get out the way really quickly
because the Russians can locate where
the artillery was fired from so we have
to move away before they return fire
Crews can monitor their targets from
small commercial drones back where they
are hidden away from Russian drones they
can take a moment to rest
now we dominate they are slowly
retreating Russians used all reserves so
they can only reach our front lines he
has a wife and child at home and says
being away from them has been tough
the situation withdrawns is complicated
they are flying always every day and
every hour
it was scary only at the beginning of
War now we just do our job even when
they fire back at us we don't panic we
are used to war
the weapons are sometimes twice as old
as the men who use them This Crew writes
the name of their fallen on missiles
we're told the majority of times the
Russians fire back quickly
This Crew has lost friends
as a commander the scariest thing is to
lose people everyone here in the
Infantry artillery and Engineering
brigades is scared to be under the
enemy's artillery fire Russians use
everything they got the crew stays out
of sight and awaits orders and
coordinates to move and fire certainly
this is a war of drones in most cases
hardly fire adjustments are made from
drones both small commercial ones and
larger ones have made the difference
the front lines have moved quickly of
late
these trenches were once facing the
enemy
Russians were closed a few months before
but now the front line is moving Jets
and drones are always flying overhead
but for observation only mostly it's
Russian drones we don't see them but
they keep flying
life is basic in the trenches but
they're waiting
here they believe in a matter of time
they will retake her son and if they do
it will be the defining moment of this
war let's not bringing I said he's
joining us from Central Ukraine with
more on this developing story so uh what
are we hearing about this reported
Russian withdrawal from clarison
but we've also heard from the Russian
general Sergey srivikin now what he said
is under the present conditions the
settlements her son and the settlements
around it can't be properly protected
and what they've said is that they want
to withdraw the troops to the east side
of that danipro River now the reason
that the Russians are giving is that
they believe that they have information
that the ukrainians want to Target that
drone now that damn sorry so in the
run-up to what we're seeing now and what
we're hearing now both sides have been
accusing each of us each other of
wanting to blow up that Dam further up
River now if that happens it will flood
a great deal of area the president
zelensky has said it would be a disaster
but it would put a natural barrier
between the Ukrainian forces and the
Russian forces so the the Russians are
accusing the ukrainians of wanting to
build that up even in the run-up to this
both sides have been accusing each other
of damaging that damn her son for a
while it was without water and
electricity but the ukrainians have also
responded and they say they don't take
the Russian statement seriously they
believe in actions and what they think
is not a withdrawal in fact the military
command in mikalayev has said that they
don't rule out Russian provocation and
the creation of false Impressions and
one of the advisors to the president
Ukrainian president has said actions
speak louder than words there's no signs
that Russia is withdrawing from her son
right so put this into context for us I
said and tell us if the withdrawal
actually does go ahead I mean what does
this all mean
well this is the only Regional Capital
that Russia has managed to take since
the start of the war it's the only point
in the country where Russian troops on
the west side of that denipro River now
the Russian officials have been really
talking up this battle for her son
they've been saying that it will be a
decisive one some of them even likened
it to the World War II Battle of
Stalingrad where they were estimated 2
million casualties now if they withdraw
is a gateway to the South also a gateway
to Crimea it also uh from Horizon
there's a fresh water supply to Annex
Crimea which is Russia annexed in 2014
and when they did that the ukrainians
cut off fresh water supply but when the
Russians took her son they reinstated
that so again this is strategically and
militarily important to both sides but
also if the ukrainians managed to take
person in the capital and some of that
region it opens up Russian troops to the
Ukrainian attacks further to the east so
yes it's very strategic but also
political this is political for Vladimir
Putin this will be seen as a massive
defeat no matter how they try to spin
this if they actually withdraw this is a
defeat it's a decisive battle they've
been saying and it looks like they're
withdrawing from person City although
the ukrainians are still not buying it
at this point in time all right thank
you so much that's a big reporting from
Central Ukraine for us